well
one person is dead and another was
seriously injured after an accident in
reason jones how are you greetings cristian
cásseres informative consular of news
now in Spanish 1 with a driver of
one I wrote and drove on basso road
without its lights this term is ended up
crashing into  another vehicle in front
the passenger of the vehicle an 83-
year-old woman was taken to the hospital where
the 75-year-old driver who
caused this accident died is in
critical condition this incident is still
under investigation I believe that
governor sticks is the one who announced that
the  residents of nevada no longer have
to wear a face mask make it clear
that those who feel comfortable
using it may continue to do so and
will not be prosecuted cases and
hospitalizations decreased in the state
despite the fact that the latest variant increased and
had a record of positive cases of 10
January ceased the one that said to leave the
description of hospitals, clinics,
schools and businesses.  If ios still want to
ask their workforce to
continue to wear a mask, they
should go to the
cord county school board on Thursday to discuss
issues such as the increase in absences in
schools a report indicates that
students are missing more
and more classes  and this has a direct impact
on your grades and we close by taking
a look at the temperatures as
we can see the
nice days here in the valley continue with highs
in the 70s some
40 mph winds expected during the
afternoon but it won't affect the
warm temperatures for today I am Cristian
Cásseres with his brief informative of
news now the Spanish good day
[Music]